2010
okay so like quick version was like I
gone through like the death of both my
parents right around 0.506 and then I go
through this terrible situation with my
brother I had to put my brother in
prison for let's just say bad management
yeah we didn't want to bring it up yeah
it's okay I mean like if I bring it up
it means like I'm cool to talk about it
kind of thing
and then I went through the cooldown of
my peer everything was coming up like
the period of cooldown in a career
and that was at the end of it and then I
was also getting smashed by Comics that
now I can say at 50 what I probably
couldn't say then without maybe looking
bad like a lot of jealousy a lot of
animosity that I at a young age was
famous hanging around with beautiful
women rich and there was a lot of and I
learned years later and I can actually
confirm that a lot of these same people
came to me years later I was like I was
just really [ __ ] like I was
frustrating I wanted to have more of
what you had anyway I mean do you were
selling out it was a 10-year run man it
was 10-year run of like every thing I
could have wanted to have happened in
the world of stand up and then all these
things Beyond it and by 10 2010
I was like
you know what I never want to do to
other Comics especially because I love
comedy and comedians but I was so hurt
by them I was so [ __ ] like let down
in some ways by the comedy community not
the guys I came up with that came up
Burr Patrice Goldman Bobby Kelly like I
had a pod of love from the graduating
class but
Beyond it there were so many like
preconceived notions of who I was and I
was getting at first it was a little fun
because you're like oh I'm kind of like
I'm the Target and then it got like kind
of ugly and then then things were like
unnecessarily pinned On Me by 2010 I was
so
um hurt in like disenfranchised that I
was like I could either go into myself
and just like take what I've earned and
go somewhere and be like [ __ ] everybody
I was like or I can just like for the
next generation of comics not be that
which was to me and that was a major
moment in my life where I was like I
truly felt after talking to him and then
a couple of times later being like
I'm gonna do this for everybody I can I
make myself available as I'm not really
quite a mentor I'm not at that age yet
but like I'm not gonna [ __ ] reject
anybody the way I've been rejected
and I don't to this day and that's why
we got to Cheers on it last night to be
like dude yeah you know we overcame a
lot of uh slings and arrows to be
in a very healthy and you know
well-adjusted spot man yeah how can you
say you're not a mentor you were the
you're the best of the best teaching
people like that's a mentor right and
what age do you think you become a
mentor at I don't think I was ready to
um I don't I don't think at that period
if you'd given me any other award to say
like now you're in now you're a provider
of this yeah I was actually rejecting
certain things that I was earning with
my hard work because I was like I'm so
tired of being a Target I don't I just
don't even want any Spotlight on me at
this time I was actually rejecting
certain
places where I probably would have
enjoyed myself more because I literally
was like just tired of the spanking
machine that I was dealing with and it
took a lot of great you know reflection
great therapy to finally know like oh no
I know what my purpose I know where my
place is then and I definitely know
where my place is now
it gets tired shoveling money all day
I hired somebody to do it what do you
think I shoveled my own money sadly it
was his brother
that was that was more like a that was a
plow yeah I wish it was just a shovel
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude